one year ago I took office amid two wars
an economy rocked by a severe recession
a financial system on the verge of
collapse and a government deeply in debt
experts from across the political
spectrum warned that if we did not act
we might face a second depression so we
acted immediately and aggressively and
one year later the worst of the storm
has passed hi I'm Michael Moynihan for
reason TV and today we are talking to
Martin Boris the director of overdose
the next financial crisis Martin this
movie it is a feature-length film about
50 50 minutes or so it is based on Johan
Norberg book a financial Fiasco that
deals with the past yeah what happened
this is about the next financial crisis
give us an overview of what the film is
about what you're trying to achieve yeah
well I started reading Johan's book and
actually he dedicates it to his son and
it says that Alexander you will look
back on this as the good old times and
that frightened me and we try to look
into why would this be the good old
times well the reason is we're repeating
yesterday's mistakes today which will
cause tomorrow's crisis what are some of
the mistakes that you point out in the
film that need to be avoided right cheap
money low interest rates cheap money the
visible hand trying to fix stuff that
the invisible hand should fix better so
this this film is now in Washington DC
as it is competing in the politics on
film festival that is this weekend
what's uh how did you guys get involved
with this and what's the what's the sort
of point of the festival here right well
you know coming from Sweden doing an
international movie we just want to get
the word out and a festival that's who
which impatient ambition is to show the
best political films in the world
in the political capital of the world
one that seems to be the place to be how
many in how many films were submitted to
seven films were selected out of a
hundred so it's no we're really glad and
excited to be taking part of it reason
obviously is a libertarian magazine
libertarian leading magazine a
free-market magazine is it fair to call
this film a libertarian film is the
message a free-market message give us a
give us an idea of what you're trying to
argue in this film well actually we were
called the market liberal Michael Moore
back home in sweden i don't know if
that's a compliment or not but at least
it's give you an idea of how people
perceive the film you know it's i don't
say that it's a libertarian movie but of
course we try to show that the
government maybe isn't the one you want
to whose hand you want to hold when it
blows yeah yeah and we're trying to show
that well of course wall street had a
lot to do with the crisis but if the
government wouldn't have been there to
to hold their backs I don't think none
of this would have happened so are you
updating this film yawns book obviously
covers the crash are you updating this
film to talk about bailouts and what the
government yeah has done in the wake of
this disaster the host book deals really
from 9-11 until Lehman Brothers for and
where's that that's about one-third of
the movie the second third is about 2008
2009 the bailout the stimulus on that
and the third part is about the future
and as we see now in Greece the future
is already here yeah so in Greece is the
kind of worst-case scenario forever
Greece's and you know Britain can be
next in line UK the US as you know is
the national depth and another number of
other figures are quite bad as well so
so how does the
what is the response to the film so far
in your home country obviously your home
country is Sweden much more of a welfare
state country than this one is much more
of a media that is to the left of the
American media have you been attacked
have you have you gotten an easy time
how's it going actually it's it's just
it's very fresh the TV premiere is on
Sunday back home in sweden so it's just
out of the editing room the the response
so far has been overwhelming but not
from everybody because I don't think
that everybody has kind of discovered it
yet so I think the next month or so will
show whether people think that this is
and that's overwhelmingly positive yeah
so far not good you never know it could
be overwhelming yeah in Sweden know
people because this I mean it you are
challenging conventional wisdom yeah
right i mean the conventional wisdom is
that had agreed capitalism free market
though that that was the failure of
course crisis and when you say that's
not true right who are some of the
people you talk to in the film some of
the talking heads and and it was there
anything that surprised you from these
people well we had the opportunity to
speak with vernon smith the nobel prize
winner in economics with the peter
schiff the investor gerald Celente the
trend forecaster megan mcardle over at
that if the Atlantic David Walker the
former comptroller general of the US and
what was so exciting was that these
people forecasted the last crisis and
they were mocked and now they're saying
that we still have the worst in front of
us and that was scary but you know
another hand exciting because it gave us
the opportunity to say that hey guys
maybe should listen to us hmm did you
talk to any people that desired more
regulation and said that you know really
wasn't a government failure it was a
market failure actually we we tried to
to get in touch with a couple of those
people but I think that most of them
thought that well they have gotten their
views out already we spoke with the
Robert phone order who used to be the
chief economist
Freddie Mac and you know he he was
balanced I don't think he agrees that
Freddie Mac had that big of a plane that
that we maybe thought but mostly we
wanted to give air to voices that really
haven't had been heard before yeah at
least not in sweden so what is what is
the the goal for this film I mean you
have a television premiere in Sweden you
have a festivals here and and Miami are
you looking for a sort of commercial
distribution what's what's the end goal
here yeah well of course we won't ask
many people to see it as possible then
the good thing about being a filmmaker
is that I don't have the answers you
know I think that the audience has the
answers but they need to discuss the
problem and the film is our attempt to
get people to start a discussion
obviously we want to have asked many
people seeing it as possible on the
other hand on one hand we would like to
distribute right now at itunes at Vogler
at you know the Pirate Bay would ever
just get it out on that on the other
hand some major television channels have
shown interest and you don't really want
to you know so we're so tell scheduling
major television channels in the UK in
the US the u.s. in the US have Shannon
can you give us an idea of who they are
no no so but this oh yes all right all
right both it would be the first to know
okay good and this would obviously
prevent you but you do have that
instinct though to release it on
piratebay on the horse everyone everyone
to watch it you know why is that I mean
is it because the message is more
important to you in a way or or you know
or you don't think you're going to make
that much money on it no we're not doing
this for the money we're doing this for
the discussion and you know to be honest
I think that if we would get the word
out on the internet that would create
the bus that really would make the major
channels interested as well I don't
think that they are that you know well
it's mark yeah yeah so smart it's by a
smart Martin Moyes director of overdose
the next financial crisis thanks for
being resolved it was pleasure thank you